I just want to protect her you know I
don't want her to go through anything I
want to Justin Bieber doesn't want Billy
Eilish to lose it like he did you I
don't wish that upon anybody yeah if she
ever needs me I'm I'm just a call away
during an interview with beats one
Zelo Justin started tearing up when he
said he wants to protect the 18 year old
singer as her fame continues to
skyrocket are you ready for the next
level of superstardom no no I think I am
honestly you know I think I I feel like
without really realizing it through
destiny silly recently made history at
the 2020 Grammy Awards by becoming the
youngest person ever to win the four
main categories Billy crazy night it was
hard for me being that young and being
in the industry and not knowing where to
turn and everyone you know telling me
they love me and you know just turn
their back on you in a second um so if
she ever needs me I'm gonna be here for
her but um yeah just protecting those
moments because people take for granted
uh encounters and I just want to protect
her he's so sweet and like I feel I just
honestly I feel for him man he's he's
gone through a lot dude
Billy who is a super fan of the Biebs
shared the emotional clip on Instagram
the bad guy singer also posted a
throwback photo of herself wearing a
Justin Bieber t-shirt and showed off her
room at the time decked out in believer
posters when did your love for the Biebs
starts
you know what it started when I was like
12 I believe and that was like right
before he retired what did you have
posters in your room I did yeah
big-ass ones silly captioned the series
of photos with stream changes Justin's
new album which dropped on Valentine's
Day going through changes bieber
commented on the post writing love you
while hailey gave her a heart emoji
[Music]
justin has been really vulnerable lately
he also opened up about his new album
and how it's basically about his wife
you know this is an album I wrote in the
first year of our marriage you know so
it's like it's so fresh and there's you
know there's no there's so much more to
learn about commitment and you know
building trust and foundation I'm just
I'm looking forward to continuing to
build and make music that's gonna
reflect that
[Music]